the story of the lord of the rings the
story of middle earth
grew over his entire life he really
spent his entire life working
[Music]
hi i'm dr corey olson the tolkien
professor and this is
every race in middle earth we're going
to be looking at the races
in middle earth as tolkien created them
mapping his creative process
over time tolkien professionally was a
philologist
that is to say he studied the history of
languages so
what was his hobby his hobby was
inventing languages
languages have a flavor to me which are
i never understand people think the same
phrases
was awfully dry and double because the
new language to me is just like taking a
new wine or
some new sweet beetle or something the
very first stage
of tolkien's creative life was what i
call his early mythology
when he was writing these ancient myths
trying to sort of explain how things
came to be
then he began in the middle of his life
this new little story
right he started the hobbit and the lord
of the rings and originally those
weren't connected
to that first stage but then he decided
to marry
his new story with his early mythology
so put together
all of these things span his creative
life and we're going to look at how
every race in middle earth developed
over the course of that time
he loved traditional fairy stories
he loved stories about elves there are
lots of places in england where a
certain
river or whale or ruin or something
associated with elves from ancient days
so one of the things that he really
wanted to do he wanted to write
a mythology for england england didn't
have a really good
fairy tale tradition the kinds of fairy
tales that they told
were mostly fairy tales from other
countries so what he ended up doing then
was going back to the languages they
form a story because he's talking about
how the languages change over time
he wanted to have peoples who were
speaking
these languages and a history that would
lead them
to do the things that he was imagining
happening the core story of his original
mythology
is that the elves live off to the west
across the sea pretty much inaccessible
most of the time but there is a mariner
a human
sailor who makes it across the sea to
elvenhome
right to tollaresia and meets the elves
and talks with them and they tell him
all the stories he writes down the set
of stories which talking called the book
of lost tales
there's a lot that could be said there
but i want to focus on what's important
for tolkien's
creative development the history of the
elves as a vehicle for his
language creation was the thing that was
really central
for tolkien in the end the major
division between the elves are
those who stayed in middle earth and
never left it and those who went
to valinor the ones who remain in middle
earth are the two primary groups called
the sindar
and the nandor these are basically
wood elves the nandor are the ones who
will become famous in
the uh the hobbit in the lord of the
rings the ones who go across
the elves who go to valinor who make it
to valinor
are the high elves the primary thrust of
the story is that there's a rebellion
among the high elves some of the high
elves return
to middle earth rebelling against the
valar it banished
um from valinor as a consequence but
they come back
in order to fight the big enemy uh
melchor
was his name and the elves renamed him
morgoth and the wars
between the high elves who returned to
middle earth and
morgoth that is the central drama of the
whole early mythologies
the elves are very strong and they're
very heroic but they're fighting against
essentially a god and they get
beaten down and beaten down and until
finally they are almost all destroyed
in middle earth and then there is the
sudden
shift and the valar relent and come to
their aid
and stomp morgoth in the war of wrath
at the end of what will later be called
the first stage this early mythological
period
tolkien in the middle of his life begins
to write a new story it began
long ago the hobbit was started
as a story that he wrote for his kids
right which
almost accidentally got shared with the
publisher who really liked it and wanted
to publish it
um so this was not like a major creative
undertaking that tolkien took
it was a thing that kind of happened by
chance he'd been trying to get published
for years
mostly failing anyway with his core
major stories and then
this funny little story that he had made
up for his kids gets published and
becomes a massive success
but in that story he basically recycles
a lot of material he had all this great
material and so we can see
the elves in the hobbit both
the wood elves of mirkwood and the high
elves which we primarily meet in
rivendell
are very much borrowed from very similar
to
not identical to but very similar to the
elves of his mythology
the sequel of course grows into the lord
of the rings
so even when tolkien enters what i call
the integration stage
of his career when he's writing this new
story and the sequel the lord of the
rings really begins to kind of take off
on him and become something bigger
and greater than the hobbit was and he
decides at that point that it should be
part of the world but he's going to
combine it with the early mythology
um so that it's all going to make one
big huge story even after he makes that
decision
the elves don't really change the elves
are a baseline for tolkien they were the
core
element of his mythology from the very
beginning in a lot of ways
they were the premise the point of the
whole mythology from the beginning
now in this mythology that tolkien has
invented for his world
started with stories about elves but
they have to have a world first
so how is the world created and how does
it work and so he invented a sort of
higher mythology
which involves a pantheon of gods now
the gods that he
included are inspired by greek
gods norse gods and finnish
mythology as well tolkien's world that
he invented was from the beginning
fundamentally monotheistic there is one
creator god who created all things and
his name was eru
the one or eluvitar tolkien almost
always gives everybody
at least two names alouvitar creates all
things but
eluvitar tolkien's god is a delegator
right the first thing that he does is he
creates
a group of spiritual beings uh who are
his companions and those are called
collectively
the inur these sort of angelic spirits
they
help to create the world and the way
that tolkien describes this
uh is what he calls the music of the
inur it is through music
that the world is created they sing a
song
the chorus of the inor and their song
is the song of the creation of the world
after the world is created some of the
inor
some of these spiritual beings who are
with the louvitar uh in the timeless
halls
decide to enter into the world itself
arda
you've got the universe that is and
you've got arda which is which is the
little world
some of the einor decide that they are
going to enter into that right that
they're going to go down and they're
going to shape it
and they're going to guide its history
just as they participated
in its creation those of the inor who
descend in the greatest of them are
called
the valar these are the the primary gods
of tolkien's mythology they are often
called gods by the mortals elves and men
and others
who live in middle earth there are also
a lot of
minor spirits which are associated with
the valor so there are spirits of the
air and there are spirits of the earth
and there are spirits of the water the
minor spirits are called
mayar but of course there was conflict
right and the conflict starts at the
very beginning the conflict starts
during the music
the greatest of all of the inor rebelled
and he created a discord within the
music
his name was melkor and many other
spirits
attuned their song to his instead of to
the sort of the greater music that a
louvitar had originally
propounded to them was tolkien's word so
melchor
he is the bad guy right and he also
descends into arda as well and claims it
for his own thinking that he should rule
it and the conflict
uh between the valar and melkor and then
between the elves and melkor
is the primary plotline of tolkien's
early mythology and one of the greatest
of his servants
is the guy who will later be known as
sauron the primary villain of the lord
of the rings
when tolkien's story then shifts right
when he starts writing his new story
the hobbit there are a bunch of ways in
which we can see these old mythological
concepts of the ainur
influencing the story but probably the
most famous
moment where these spiritual beings
appear
in tolkien's new story is tom bombadil
and goldberry tom bombadil is a strange
character
he's clearly one of the inor um he talks
about coming in from the outside he
talks about being there
in arda you know in in middle earth from
the very beginning
he is one of these spirits who has taken
on physical form and entered into
the world and his wife goldberry uh
is the daughter of the river the biggest
and most dramatic
effect of the integration of his new
story with his old mythology
as far as the inor are concerned is the
wizards
if you just read the hobbit and focus on
nothing but the hobbit
gandalf seems to be a dude who is a
professional wizard
this idea changes and when it changes
most dramatically
is when tolkien decides to integrate the
old mythology
with the news story and so here he
decides the wizards
are in fact einor powerful but lesser
spirits are not valor
but they are some of the the more
powerful servants of the valar the valar
have looked out in this third age as
sauron is growing more powerful and the
great elf kingdoms of old are gone
the great human kingdoms of old are gone
who can possibly oppose
sauron as he rises to power again the
wizards
are the help they are incarnated into
bodies
and they are brought to middle earth and
they go about middle-earth
trying to help uh the peoples gandalf
is the one who is the highest profile he
does the most good
sauron of course fails right sarman
fails and he fails
most spectacularly there are of course
three other wizards the one who is
mentioned in the text is radagast the
brown
whom we're told is a particular friend
to beasts and birds
we're not told very much at all else
about
radagast the brown we know even less
about the other two wizards
whom tolkien later said were blue
wizards they went off into the east
and tolkien never did tell the story
about what happened to them
but gandalf as i said becomes the
centerpiece he becomes
the wizard who succeeds and who is the
primary instrument
of the valar in helping middle earth in
this final
stage and his primary role the thing
that he does is he goes around and he
inspires hope
in people that is the primary mission of
gandalf the grey
who becomes gandalf the white this by
the way is why gandalf is able to be
resurrected
because he's not just a guy he is one of
the mayar who is given a body and that's
why when gandalf comes back he's
different
that was what they used to call me but
he's more powerful
because he's been given a new body and
been given a new job he's done his job
well
and he is empowered to return and finish
the job
which he does through the end of the
word of the rings
we have elves and we have men those two
together are called the children of a
louvitar the primary difference between
elves and men
is longevity elves do age very
very slowly but they don't die of old
age
their life is coterminous with the earth
humans
only live a short time here within arda
and then they die
and their spirits go somewhere else the
primary dimension that differentiates
elves and men
is their connection with arda humans
however
when their spirits depart they leave
arda behind entirely
the humans are called the after comers
the ones who are born second
the most important human story that
tolkien wrote was the story of numenor
there are some surviving men who have
survived the wars and who have been
faithful who have been the allies of the
elves and the valar
say we're going to make you a special
land so they create them an
island called numenor in the island of
numenor
the men grow to be wiser greater
they are longer lived they live like 200
250 300 years they
become taller they're just blessed in
every way the numenoreans
and they become the most amazing group
of men ever in the history of the world
but they become discontented they long
for
immortal life they don't want to die
they don't want to leave the world and
so they try to find ways to make
themselves immortal
so increasingly the numenoreans become
discontent
and then they meet sauron the last
numenorean king
sets out to conquer him and he takes
sauron
captive and he's brought back to numenor
and when sauron
is in numenor he swiftly becomes the
chief counselor
of the king and convinces him to attack
the valar themselves
and to take the immortal land by force
where they
have become convinced that they will
live immortally if they manage to
conquer
the undying lands and the louvitar
smites
the island of numenor and it sinks
beneath the sea
almost all of the numenoreans died but a
few of them survive
there are a few numenoreans a subset of
the population who are still faithful
to their old friendship with the elves
and the valar and they established
themselves the last
exiled remnants of numenor in
middle earth itself the survivor
of numenor was named alendo and he gets
together with the last
king of the high elves remaining in
middle earth
and the two of them formed the last
alliance of elves and men
and they go and they attack sauron and
they throw him down
for good and all isildur elendil's son
cuts
the ring from his hand the overthrow of
sauron
is the end of the early mythology but as
he's
writing the lord of the rings things
start to
come together and in particular that
story of numenor which was so important
to tolkien frodo and the hobbits as
they're leaving the shire
encounter strider the ranger in bree
strider becomes their guide and takes
them to rivendell
and this is how we meet the character of
aragorn
who is the uh the heir of isildur and
the future king of gondor
the heir of numenor he becomes the
dunadine
now dunadine is the word that's used in
the lord of the rings
for the descendants of numenor the
descendants of numenor are still
among us in middle earth their
descendants are lesser it's been a long
time since numenor
but there are there are still
descendants of the great people among us
gondor in particular
is where the people of middle earth
joined together
with the descendants of the numenoreans
and together they made
a kingdom which in middle earth recalled
the splendor of numenor that was
the eagles are really important
characters in tolkien's stories
from the beginning in the early
mythology the eagles are spirits they
are einor they are some of the servants
of manway some of the chief servants of
manway
manway of course was the leader of the
pantheon right he was
essentially the king of middle earth and
he was the god of the air
and when the eagles come rolling in it
means that
manway is taking a hand directly in
events
they are also one of the elements where
we can see most clearly
that tolkien was not just imagining the
hobbit as part of his
old mythology world from the beginning
even in the hobbit
the eagles come by the end of the story
to recall
the eagles of manway in some ways the
high point
of the whole hobbit story is bilbo
crying out
the eagles are coming which is not only
this miraculous rescue there but again
there's an
almost supernatural element there in the
lord of the rings
as the story develops and as he
integrates the new story with the old
mythology
the eagles become the mechanisms by
which the valar are still taking a hand
and helping
the people of middle earth this of
course bears on the question which many
people have asked
why don't they just fly on eagles uh to
take the ring to mordor one reason why
they don't do that is that that would be
a really bad story
the second reason they would be really
easy to see coming
and sauron has an air force too the
third reason
the eagles are not mounts right it's
thinking of them completely
wrong they are not just birds they are
certainly not just
mounts and so when they come in they are
allies who might be able to
intervene as they do intervene again at
the very end of the lord of the rings at
the battle of the black gate
they are allies and they seem by
implication to be allies
sent even by the valar to help in
extreme times of need you know what they
awoke in the darkness
shadow one of the most dramatic
characters in the lord of the rings
is the balrog of moria right and
everybody loves the confrontation
between gandalf
and the balrog on the bridge of khazadu
the balrogs are really old characters
they are there almost from the beginning
in tolkien's mythology
melkor of course the big bad guy when he
comes into arda
at the beginning he brings with him many
spirits the balrogs are the chief of
those
the balrogs and sauron served together
under morgoth so when gandalf is
confronting the balrog on the bridge of
kazadoom it is a big
big deal they are associated with
shadows and darkness but mostly with
flame
and especially their whips of flame
if this is some clotted idea of a joke
i can only say foretaste
dwarves have perhaps the most dramatic
evolution
of any of the races in tolkien's world
in the original mythology dwarves are
bad guys
they're servants of morgoth they're like
right alongside the orcs
tolkien not only does not emphasize
that they're very skilled craftsmen he
says explicitly that they're not
skilled craftsmen all they care about is
the bottom line when tolkien is writing
his new story his hobbit story he wants
to include
dwarfs heavily influenced by the dwarves
of his mythology and remember the
dwarves in his mythology
are not anything to brag about they are
not
heroes but here's the thing as he's
writing the story
the dwarves transform the dwarves change
a lot
over the course of the hobbit itself in
chapter one when they show up on bilbo's
doorstep
and they're explaining to bilbo what
happened thorin
sings a song
all of a sudden the dwarves are
craftsmen and they talk about
their works of hand and all of the
beautiful things that they made
that idea emerges there in the hobbit
and becomes this dominant part of the
story so that when the dwarves get back
to their treasure
it's no longer just about the money it's
now about
recovering the work of their fathers and
their homeland of old
and it becomes a really moving story and
thorin
becomes a really interesting character
he has his really bad moment where he's
threatening to throw bilbo off the wall
victim of the dragon sickness and
becoming overwhelmed by his desire for
the treasure and his greediness
but he turns away from it and in the end
thorin oakenshield
dies as sacrificial death dwarves kind
of become
heroes over the course of the hobbit the
new story
changes the old mythology so when he
brings the two things together
in his later career he ends up having to
change stuff about dwarves but over the
course of the lord of the rings in
particular we can see
him beginning to develop further this
idea of
who the dwarves are and what they're
like they become clearly
one of the free people and now dwarves
elves
and men together become the core
of what tolkien calls the free peoples
of middle earth there are several places
in the lord of the rings
that allude to the fact that the origins
of the dwarves are uncertain
right that nobody's really sure about
where the dwarves came from
well one of the reasons for this was
that tolkien was unsure
where dwarfs came from he invented some
stories and he eventually decided
that they were made by the god aole the
valo who is in charge of the earth of
stone but also of craftsmanship
he was the smithing god and he makes
dwarves to be his helpers but he doesn't
really have the authority but a louvitar
has pity on them
and spares them and he infuses them the
dwarves
uh with some of his own will so we still
have the two children of iluvatar
elves and men and the dwarves become the
stepchildren of the louvitar
retconning in tolkien's mythology now
the orcs
are the primary bad guys if you're
fighting
the armies of evil on the fields of
middle earth it's probably orcs that
you're fighting
orcs were part of the original mythology
the word orc
was derived from tolkien's elvish
languages orcs were basically constructs
they were manufactured by morgoth these
were not independent races
tolkien says that morgoth made them in
mockery
of elves morgoth filled the orcs with
his
spirit of hatred and cruelty that's the
role of orcs
in tolkien's early mythology and this is
a really important
idea this mythic concept of this
embodied evil
is an important element that we can see
running through the lord of the rings
when tolkien starts writing his new
story in his hobbit story
he included goblins now he calls them
goblins
instead of orcs orc and goblin are in
tolkien's world
really synonyms goblins of fairy tale
tradition have a lot of similarities
with the orcs of
uh of tolkien's mythology however
the orcs create what is probably the
single
biggest problem in tolkien's world
he decided in writing the lord of the
rings that
his old mythology wouldn't work in this
new context
at the end of the day he decided morgoth
could not actually create creatures
of his own right it becomes part of his
mythology that only a louvitar only god
has the ability to create a sentient
race
owlette made the dwarves but a louvitar
helps them along and adopts them
well if that's true if only a louvitar
can create sentient races then morgoth
couldn't have made the orcs
as simple constructs so tolkien develops
a second story a second version for
where orcs came from and he goes back
and he changes the mythology
if all sentient creatures can only be
created by a louvitar then logically
orcs have to be
not a new species but a corruption of an
old species morgoth back in the very
early days right after the elves awoke
by the shores of queven
morgoth captured some of them and he
brought them back to his dark domain
and he tortured them and he twisted them
and the result was the orcs the orcs are
corrupted twisted elves
now there are several different breeds
of orcs we know that the orcs of the
misty mountains
uh are sort of one way and the orcs of
mordor are bigger and stronger
but there's one major innovation that we
see in the lord of the rings and that is
the group called the urukhai and the
urukhai
are the orcs of sariman we are not told
definitively within the narrative
exactly where the urukai came from the
speculation that we are given
believes that they are a blending of the
races of orc
and men that the orc hire the results of
cross breeding
between orcs and men the interbreeding
of orcs and men does not bear thinking
about
because that could only have happened in
one of several
truly horrifying ways
[Music]
dragons are a really important part of
tolkien's world in tolkien's mythology
in the early stages of the wars between
morgoth and the elves
morgoth decides he's got to do something
to tip the scales
and so dragons are his answers he
designs the first dragon in the first
dragon the father of dragons was named
glaurung and the dragons were originally
wingless
glaurung comes out and he does the job
glaurung becomes one of
morgoth's chief captains and he'll deal
some devastating blows
uh to the elves in the wars with morgoth
and he releases the winged dragon during
the war of wrath at the end
the bad guys almost win so the dragons
have a major major role
in the early mythology now when tolkien
begins his new story
his hobbit story ultimately it's going
to be a dragon story
one minor but really interesting bad guy
in tolkien's world are werewolves now
these are not werewolves
uh in the like european tradition who
are human beings who get infected and
transform into wolves at the full moon
but these are just especially evil
wolves they're sort of more products of
morgoth's
research and development department they
are the bodies of large wolves combined
with fell spirits and it's interesting
because sauron
is actually the one who spearheads
the werewolf project the werewolves
don't come in for a whole lot of stories
however in the new story um he brings
the wolves
back in the hobbit uh the wargs are
encountered of course
right near the goblins and they're the
allies of the goblins they're kind of
borrowed from
the old werewolves of the old mythology
tradition they're intelligent
they speak their own language and they
are the mounts of the goblins but
they're the allies
when tolkien begins to integrate these
things the wargs
stay but he kind of downplays the wolves
the wolves get really kind of put aside
some orcs still ride uh wolves but the
the
wolves themselves become a lesser
character
hobbits really are amazing creatures you
may be interested by the fact that we're
only
now getting to hobbits hobbits are
really the
iconic tolkien race he might have
thought about elves
first and foremost but for the modern
reader in the modern audience it's all
about the hobbits
hobbits emerged when he started writing
his
new story in fact tolkien was so poor
that he
signed up to grade exams so there was
one essay he was in the middle of
grading it right and he flips over the
page and they left a page blank
and so on this blank page he takes his
pen and he writes
in a hole in the ground there lived a
hobbit and he had no idea what a hobbit
was
so the first story of the hobbit story
was him figuring out what a hobbit was
and he decided
that hobbits were these funny little
people and he developed the whole hobbit
culture
which has become absolutely beloved
by modern readers the world of the
hobbits really kind of took over
the original seed of the lord of the
rings story was the long expected party
bilbo's farewell party where he brings
in all of his relatives
uh and then insults them and shocks them
all and beca
and vanishes and hands things off to
frodo but tolkien didn't know
what frodo was gonna do or where he was
gonna go as the story of the lord of the
rings develop the hobbits
don't really change very fundamentally
their culture remains
very much the same their role of course
becomes really important
and them as the the representative
of the little people of small people who
are not themselves very important
yet accomplishing big things becomes one
of the major themes
of the word of the rings now tolkien
never really explains so it seems the
most likely explanation
within tolkien's mythology of hobbits is
that they are somehow a subspecies of
men
that at some point and for some reason
became small
there are other sub-races of men that he
introduced kind of like hobbits in this
way
humans in tolkien's world are kind of
malleable
where that came from one of the other
bad guy races
are trolls in tolkien's world and
they're weird they're funny they speak
in cockney accents
the trolls are really just kind of fun
characters fun villains that he invents
on his own the chief characteristic
of the trolls apart from you know being
large
strong not very intelligent and
man-eating
is that they turn into stone when the
sun shines on them
because they in fact permanently turn
into stone statues
if sunlight falls upon them that's of
course the story in the hobbit it's how
they escape from the trolls
look furto it's mr bilbo's trolls
now tree beard the ant tells us in the
lord of the rings
that the trolls are made by the enemy
in mockery of ants as the orcs were of
elves
trolls were sort of animated stone just
as
ants are kind of animated trees right um
that they are creatures who are
fundamentally made out of stone
and who are enslaved to the will of
sauron
it's talking mary the tree is talking
tree
i am no tree giants have an
interesting history in tolkien's world
giants are of course a staple
of traditional fairy tales stories in
the early mythology there are some
references to giants it seems like
giants kind of exist but he never really
told any stories about giants
tree beard originally in tolkien's idea
was one was a jack and the beanstalk
style
giant but at the same time
this other idea was beginning to grow in
tolkien's mind
and to begin to become an element of the
story and that is the idea of sentient
trees which can communicate even in a
way
and which can move and act against the
hobbits
and these trees they're not evil per se
but they're hostile
very hostile to the hobbits and they're
hostile
because from a tree's perspective these
little bipeds
right they come in with their axes and
they want to clear land for
farming right and other useless things
like that from the tree perspective
they're not servants of sauron they're
not creatures of morgoth
or anything like that they're just
territorial and they don't like
bipeds much at all the moment comes when
the hobbits come mary and pippen of
course are coming to fangorn forest
another ancient forest down in the
southern part of the world
in that moment tolkien has one of these
flashes of inspiration
which just transformed things and he
realizes wait a second
this is a giant who is a tree and he
becomes treebeard the ant
as soon as he makes this decision as
soon as he realizes no this is not a
jack and the beanstalk style
giant we're talking about here the
entire chapter the entire tribute
chapter chapter 4 of book 3
of the two towers emerges almost word
for word
in one draft the story of treebeard
and the ants how they were woken up and
taught language by the elves
all comes together in one shot
in the two towers we have tree beard in
the ends but we also have this
middle class of creatures called who
horns and
as they are related to trees some of the
trees wake up
and learn to talk back so who horns are
in fact a sort of middle stage they're
wakeful trees or they're sleepy ants so
when the who worns come in and armies of
horns
take out the army of orcs after the
battle of helm's deep
and invade eisenguard that's what
tolkien's talking about
one of tolkien's favorite villains from
the beginning were giant
spiders from the very beginning of his
mythology one of his big villains was
named
unguliant the gloom weaver and she's a
gigantic spider
she is like the embodiment of darkness
itself
and her role in the early stories in the
early mythologies
she is an ally of morgoth now angolia
did have
children she had a brood of giant spider
uh offspring uh which then go on to
trouble the land and to become
characters and other stories
we have of course the giant spiders of
mirkwood that mirkwood
is a dark place where light is choked
off and in the midst
of this dark and gloomy forest is the
spider colony
we're also told that they're bitter
enemies of the wood elves
so when tolkien came to write the lord
of the rings he decided early on
when frodo and sam were going to get
into mordor one of the last
obstacles they were going to have to
pass was giant spiders
sauron is with morgoth from the
beginning sauron was
originally one of the servants of aole
the god of
craftsmanship this is why he becomes the
one who forges the rings of power
the story of the forging of the rings of
power however
comes a good deal later and in fact that
does not originate in the early
mythology at
all it originates from the new story
when tolkien is writing the hobbit he
includes the necromancer
at the end of the hobbit we are told
that gandalf went to meet with all the
other wizards
and kicked the necromancer out of
southern mirkwood
when tolkien sits down to write the
sequel he quickly
fixes on the necromancer as a very
likely antagonist for the sequel
he decided to send his hobbit
protagonists on an adventure
and they hear the sound of hoof beats
coming up the road from behind them now
they think this is probably gandalf
in the very first draft when tolkie
wrote this a horse comes around the
corner and it is gandalf
uh he goes back to where he had said
it was a white horse he decided it was a
wraith and it was a wraith in the
service of the necromancer
and that it is hunting for frodo why
would it be hunting
for frodo and as he begins to work this
out the whole story
of sauron and the rings of power begins
to emerge
he puts his own will to dominate the
wills of others
into the ring of power he convinces
kelebrimbor
one of the old high elves to stay in
middle earth after the war of wrath he
convinces him
to forge other rings of power and his
idea is to use those lesser rings of
power
to ensnare the leaders of all of the
good races
but it doesn't work because the elves
figure out what he's up to
um he ends it with the survivors of the
numenoreans and the last of the high
elves joining together
in the last alliance of elves and men to
take down
sauron he inserts the ring of power now
into that story
and says that at that time they cut the
ring of power
from salons and is eventually found by
bilbo in the hobbit
and comes to frodo here in the lord of
the rings
so one of the things that sauron made
were these nine rings he tried to
ensnare
all of the races it didn't work out he
gives his nine
rings of power to nine kings among the
different human cultures
of the time and he ensnared them
by the promise of immortality that he
delivers on that promise
in a warped and twisted way their wills
become enslaved to him
and they are in fact stretched out but
they don't even have bodies anymore
right they become tormented spirits who
are chained
to this world so the ring raids as we
see them
they are his most terrible servants they
are themselves
enslaved in a way that is uh that goes
beyond
uh the power of their own lives and
keeps them
here in this world there are two other
categories of tormented spirits that i
would mention in particular
the hobbits and as they're traveling out
of the shire very early on in their
journey
have to go through the barrow downs in
these barrows there seem to be unquiet
dead
who are called barrow whites and they
are sent
into the graves and they animate these
corpses the other
group of tormented spirits that we meet
are the oath breakers
these ghosts are not like barowhites
these are actually
the lingering spirits of people
who used to be alive they were a tribe
of people who lived in gondor
and who swore their allegiance to
isildur
but when isildor comes to them and calls
them up and says hey
we're going to war time for the battle
of the last alliance join us
they didn't come isildur cursed them
and said you shall never rest again
until you fulfill your oath so when
aragorn comes
he is the heir of isildor so he has the
authority
and says i'm going to give you a second
chance guys
it's now time to fulfill your oath again
and they do
and aragorn uses the army of the dead he
deploys the army of the dead
to save the day at the battle of pelenor
field but after the oath breakers help
them with that initial battle
aragorn releases them
[Music]
and that was each and every race in
tolkien's middle earth
i hope this helps you to understand a
little bit better about how tolkien's
ideas developed
and i think it's a really fascinating
study in the growth of a modern
mythology
and of course you can see how much of
modern fantasy ideas
emerged from tolkien's world